creating videos all by yourself can be
really overwhelming
i mean think about it when you watch a
movie and there's all those credits at
the end
that's who you are when you're creating
videos all
by yourself and in today's episode
sean's gonna be breaking down
his 10-step checklist for making amazing
youtube
videos my name is heather torres and i
am your host of the think marketing
podcast if you're new here welcome we
release a brand new episode
every single tuesday so make sure you
are subscribed
wherever you're consuming this content
from now today's episode is
power packed shawn is going to be
walking through the 10
step checklist that you can use on your
next
youtube video here's what's great this
is the same checklist that we are still
using here at think
from going from solo creator into having
interns and help
and now into a full-blown media company
this is the exact checklist
that we give to our students of our
video ranking academy
and we're sharing it with you here on
the podcast and
i want to let you know before we get
into this episode that we now have
open registration for our next youtube
influence challenge this is a seven day
challenge to help you
jump start your youtube channel right
this year
so i'll give you more info at the end of
this episode
let's get into today's content
hey sean cannell here and i'm fired up
to share my 10-step
youtube checklist with you and first
three powerful strategies
to help you stay productive stay
consistent on youtube
publishing videos and also do it with
more
peace of mind listen i've posted over 2
000 videos on youtube for
years i've tried to be consistent on
youtube as the shooter the editor solo
creator
probably just like you and it can be
really overwhelming and so this
checklist has helped me
not just get things done and make sure i
don't miss a step
but also reduce my stress in the process
and so here's three big strategies that
i think are key
for staying consistent on youtube when
you're trying to juggle family
school work kids
a life sleep all these other types of
things
and strategy number one and then we'll
get into the 10-step checklist
is batching batch producing now this is
not a new concept but maybe you're
hearing about it for the first time on
the think marketing podcast
and this is the clustering of similar
tasks in this case we like to shoot
multiple videos all at once to give you
an example
at the time of recording this very think
marketing podcast
we are actually going to record probably
six or seven episodes
all in one day but you don't have to go
to that level you may just want to shoot
two videos at once instead of just one
that's gonna help you get ahead
eventually you may feel comfortable
recording four videos on a saturday
morning
and then you've got a video a week for
an entire month
the idea is not just setting up your
camera setting up the lights
getting us taking a shower that day
getting you know your microphone and
your batteries charged and everything
just to shoot one video
if you're going to batch and cluster
similar tasks
take all of that energy and invested in
shooting as many videos as possible and
when i think years back when i was a
solo creator
and i would oftentimes try to shoot two
to three
to if possible four videos all in one
cluster i would go to the loft in my
house
set up my tripod set up my camera i
would print out all my notes
and put them you might use an ipad or
your phone
and i would shoot one video after
another video after another video i'd
have
all of that content on the sd card and
then it's ready for editing
after batching the second big strategy
is
block time blocking time on your
schedule
ahead of time to create a batch
of videos this might be saying that
this coming saturday from nine to noon
you're it's it's video shoot time you're
gonna record all those videos all at
once
for the recording of this series of
episodes on the think marketing podcast
this has been on my calendar for over a
month
so looking ahead at when is the next
time you're going to shoot
some videos now you also might want to
block time for editing
maybe one week you shoot three videos
all on a saturday morning
and then maybe it's two weeks later on a
thursday evening where you're going to
upload all those videos to your computer
drop them all in the timeline of your
editing software whatever your process
is
or just edit them on your phone you're
blocking time on your calendar
to get similar tasks done and
the other powerful thing about block
time is it's also focusing your energy
you know if your energy goes to a little
bit of editing and i you know i'm a new
dad so i
at the time of recording this my son
sean bradley cannell's about
eight weeks old and um i definitely
understand that when i have to do
daddy duties and try to be productive at
work
my my focus is split my energy is split
so it's a blessing when sonja can
focusly take
sean bradley so i can put all my energy
into whatever whatever i
need to get done conversely when i take
sean
bradley now sonia loses her mind she's
like i'm so productive just the fact you
took him for two hours
i was able to get so many things done
because my focus wasn't split
think about block time communicate with
your family communicate with those
around you
get help from a sister from a mom from a
friend
and put some block time where you cannot
just be fully present with your time
but also with your mind and your energy
and then number three
is get help get help you want to have a
more productive shoot day i have been
through
countless shoot days where it's just
been me in the room
right i got my camera set up feels
pretty lonely i'm talking to the lens
and you're like there's nobody here
there's nobody there to even just keep
you on track
and that can be challenging so when
possible try to get a shoot
day assistant and before you say sean i
don't have any money to hire anybody
this could look a lot of different ways
it could be again somebody that just
wants to kind of learn the ropes
and volunteer to just make sure that the
red button stays on on the camera and
it's
actually recording somebody with
headphones on someone that is a
cousin a brother a friend or maybe you
already
are a business owner and it's somebody
that can just jump in to be
present in the room with you again it
could be a spouse
it's very powerful to have a shoot day
assistant for me
um in the early days of think media as i
was transitioning
out of being a in the side hustle season
into the solopreneur season where it was
really just me earning enough to be
full-time
but not with anybody really paid beyond
some contractors here and there
i went to a local las vegas meetup
because i was looking for help
and i met a guy named jay and he said
hey i actually saw think media we had
about 16 000 subscribers
then and i saw that you go to nab here
in the city
i would love to maybe go help because he
wanted to go to nab he wanted to kind of
hang out he wanted to learn some things
and so he was actually a volunteer for a
couple months and i finally
had like a shoot day assistant and he
was learning and we were getting into
the flow of things eventually
i started paying him um kind of
part-time or just a low amount of kind
of internship money
and then eventually it grew into just
his normal rate
and we work together for a season think
about how you could scale into having a
shoot day assistant if anything
i've learned the power of accountability
if somebody
if is gonna have to actually be there
waiting for you at 9 a.m
on saturday during your shoot day batch
and your shoot day block time
it's a whole nother level because now
you have a person that's on the other
side that's actually
you know holding you accountable in a
way there's just something powerful
about having somebody else in the room
if possible and so those are the three
big strategies but now
let's get into the checklist number one
ten
tips for making sure your next
youtube shoot day goes awesome number
one
think about we're gonna go through the
avl the audio video and lighting we're
gonna start with video number one is
video
um before your shoot day if possible
get all your gear ready and even get it
set up before your shoot day for this
think marketing podcast recording the
gear was set up the day before
not even the morning of or even right
before the shoot
and here's what i want you to think
about i want you to think about is your
camera good to go
do you have sd cards ready and are they
cleaned off and formatted
do you have your batteries charged and
maybe even extra batteries for your
shoot day
and do you have all the little pieces
and parts
that you're going to need for your shoot
day you know i've learned this the hard
way
i have often times thought okay i'm
going to block time
get started creating content at 10 a.m
and then 10 a.m rolls around and i'm
like where is that little tripod screw
and then i'm like oh shoot the battery's
dead now i need to wait a couple hours
before i can even turn my camera on
and then i'll be like oh shoot the sd
card is full but i haven't captured this
footage yet
so i need to actually sit on my front of
my computer make sure the footage is
captured
my friend if possible get all of the
assets that are going to be recording
your video content
ready the day before your shoot day and
you're gonna feel better for it number
two
audio do you have your microphones ready
do you have
batteries for your microphones if needed
some shotgun mics i use use nine volt
batteries some use double-a batteries
many
today are either not powered or they're
powered by uh they're rechargeable make
sure they're charged up
but oftentimes when i've used like nine
volt batteries
if the mic's been dead i didn't have
another nine volt battery sitting around
now you gotta drive to the store or
potentially wait a couple days to have
some batteries shipped from amazon to
your house the same thinking
number one's video number two is audio
do you have your mic ready do you have
your audio set up and then number three
is lighting again can you set it up a
day ahead
you got your light stand you got your
soft box lights whatever it is you need
in the description we'll link to some
resources because if you're not watching
think media
for the best video audio lighting and
even stabilization resources
we've got all our current
recommendations for every budget
on our think media youtube channel so
definitely check that out
and then number four is the set if you
can set up your set
ahead of time then your shoot is going
to be better
for it this is maybe an area of your
house that you keep clean
this is maybe an area of your house
where you you figured out yes it's lit
you've put some stuff up on the wall
it's the place where you shoot
space might be limited you may not have
a place where you can have the set
set up all the time so set it up ahead
of time
if possible eventually dream about how
you could build
a permanent set somewhere so that it's
easier for you
to create content that's number four
number five
is your wardrobe and a tip here is just
the ability to rotate
layers of um of your outfit so that if
you shoot multiple videos in a batch
you could potentially have say four
outfit changes now
this is totally up to you if you want to
wear the same thing cool if you want
there to be variety in your videos great
you know if you're a female maybe you
have
different wardrobe changes that you want
to make that are more dynamic for me i
like to keep it simple and i like to do
layers today
for the recording of this very think
marketing podcast
if you are just listening on audio i'm
wearing a mint
green t-shirt and i brought a couple
different jackets in fact i'm going to
wear
a black jean jacket a gray jean jacket
a blue green jacket jean jacket and then
just no jacket and there's my four
wardrobe changes boom switching them out
one by one i've been doing this for a
few years
i've actually purposefully buy clothing
for video
since also if you're only listening on
audio this is only waist up so a lot of
it just has to do
i don't even have pants on just kidding
and so number five though
is wardrobe set that out ahead of time
and i know there's been days where
i've you know thought i was going to
wear a certain shirt and then realized
thing is wrinkled as heck now it needs
to be ironed you know you're just
thinking ahead and trying to remove
any friction and so if your wardrobe is
set out
set up ahead of time you'll be good to
go number six your video
outline to me this is bullet points
and critical call to actions now
i don't really read off a teleprompter
unless we're creating a sales video for
an online course or a
program or something that's more
detailed like that typically
i go off and outline the think media
team typically goes off an
outline and has right now i've got an
ipad in front of me
and i've got google docs open and all of
our think marketing podcasts
are outlined right here i've got my
three strategies one two three i've got
my checklist my 10 points
all outlined and that's what i'm using
to go through this content
today i think not only do you want to
have a strong video outline prepared
ahead of time but if you're going to
batch produce this is critical
so maybe you've got your three videos
outlined
what's the title what's the kind of
opening hook
what's going to kind of be the grabbing
opening idea that would make people want
to watch or listen to the end
what are the points that you want to hit
what do you want people to do
next on this think marketing podcast
episode you're hearing from heather
she's got she's actually covering the
hook
she's covering today's call to action we
say this episode's brought to you by
she's hitting all of those things i'm
focusing on the core content
and it was all outlined ahead of time
and here's a big key
for me this almost needs to be a
different day i can pull it off if i do
it like the morning of like a couple
hours and i know i'm gonna shoot later
in the day
but i've noticed it's almost like two
different sides of the brain for me
where sitting down thinking about what
i'm gonna say in the video
is one set of block time one session
and then actually delivering the content
on camera
is a second kind of side of the brain
and so i like to have if possible all of
that outlined and one power tip beyond
that
is i've found that if you want to level
up your content
finish your outline and then let it
breathe i've found that if i don't
do things last minute and then just kind
of rush and prepare my points
but if i get my points done and then i
go for a run sleep on it
think about it in the shower later you
know watch some youtube videos watch the
news
maybe an illustration pops up maybe a
tweak pops up maybe something i think
actually didn't really make sense that
was a very strong point i find that if
you let your content
breathe before you record it actually
gives you the opportunity to make
your content stronger so we talked about
number one video number two get your
audio set up number three get your
lighting right number four get your set
set up number five get your wardrobe
laid out
for your batch shooting block time
day number six get your video outline
and number seven shoot the video
so now you're gonna sit down and record
the video or the vtos
and uh we have done all these steps in
this very shoot right now
i'm talking over here on the think
marketing podcast youtube channel
right to camera we got the sd cards the
batteries we've got other batteries
being charged at the time of shooting
this
and as i mentioned today we're going to
be shooting probably six to seven
different episodes of the think
marketing podcast plus
we're also going to shoot some snippets
for social media around some of our
holiday promotions we're going to cover
a whole bunch of different things and
we're clustering it all in one day
over to my left we've got a little
clothing rack with the wardrobe changes
and and this is where we've scaled to i
mean at this point
we've got kyle and omar and heather um
in the think marketing anderson studios
uh but hey no matter what level you're
at you i don't encourage you to go from
zero to eight videos in one day
maybe just try to shoot two on a
saturday morning again by yourself with
your smartphone
following some of omar's tips from the
think media channel
but you got to shoot the content block
the time when are you going to shoot the
content and then
press record now big tip number eight
make sure to also shoot thumbnails you
know you've put a lot of work in so far
but now that you've recorded those
videos
shoot thumbnails as well and sometimes
we shoot thumbnails on entirely
different days
and we like to just get different facial
expressions different
uh stances positionings different
creative ideas for what we're going to
use for thumbnails
but if you're going to batch produce
your videos
you should also batch produce your
thumbnails
so you have a lot of thumbnails to pull
from the other thing that this will
really benefit
is it's not just the videos that you're
going to use those thumbnails for you
might use them for social media again
these are just photography these are
just pictures
if all you have is a smartphone put the
10 second timer up put it get in some
decent lighting get a decent background
and give yourself a little dropbox
folder of thumbnails of photos you can
choose from
for your videos but also for your live
streams you might be sitting
you know around on some kind of a
special day when you really think
there's an opportunity to go live and
you think shoot i don't have a good
image
of me with good lighting or maybe it's
night and it's like hard to get good
lighting
at that moment if you already have a
cluster
a batch of thumbnails to pull from
you'll be better for it and then number
nine
shoot b-roll which is another word for
extra footage if necessary
when i was creating videos for think
media back in say
2015 and i
again was doing it all and i had to
think through all these different steps
that's why i use this checklist that's
why i want you to have this checklist
because you get done spouting off on
camera
and now all of a sudden you're seeing
stars and you haven't been actually
consuming enough oxygen you know you're
just feeling a little
dizzy it's really easy to forget oh
shoot i forgot to shoot thumbnails oh my
gosh
i forgot to even mention that point
because you didn't have an outline
the other thing that you can forget is a
lot of times i like to shoot the talking
head portion of the video
knowing i'm going to lay the extra
footage over later but i don't
teach a little bit and then show with
the b-roll and then teach a little bit
and then
show the extra footage i like to lock
down the shot as we have right here
deliver all the what's called a-roll
that's all the talking head
portion of the video and then have a
list potentially
or even kind of look over my script or
look over my points
and then shoot the visuals that can
enhance
that a-roll that's why it's called
b-roll if you're in editing software
layer one a-roll layer two is the b-roll
clips
the extra footage video clips in your
editing software
that is right above the a-roll and so
for example
if i was talking about one of my
favorite cameras the canon m50 i might
go through a list of points and go
through a list of tips and go through a
list of
uh examples and explain everything i
want to explain in the video
then i have a number nine extra footage
that i start thinking okay this is what
the visual will be
during this time when i was explaining
that point and i'll get some just
general cool shots of the camera on a
table
i'll get some actual shots of using the
camera maybe from a different day
this potentially could be i may get that
extra footage ahead of time
i may get it after and i think okay my
wife sony and i
and our son we're going to go to town
square here in las vegas let me bring
the canon m50 with me
to actually shoot some examples of it in
the real world
while we're out and she's you know in a
store shopping or doing whatever
i might put the camera on a bench in the
nice sun with the cool
you know plants and the cool like you
know aesthetics that are happening in an
area like that and get the
extra footage that's going to enhance
that video thinking ahead about my
calendar where can i get the extra
footage
the b-roll clips and the shots that i
want to enhance that video
and in some cases i may shoot my four
videos in a batch
all at once on one talking head kind of
shoot day and then know that
over the next few days maybe i'm gonna
travel maybe i'm gonna do something
where i could actually
capture extra footage so what does this
come back down to my friend
planning thinking ahead six words
think things through
then follow through spending time and
planning sometimes feels
boring or sometimes feels like you're
not really being effective you're not
really being creative my friend
every minute you spend in planning
brings you a 1 000
return on your energy planning this all
out getting this locked down on a google
doc
getting this all outlined and thinking
the whole thing through is going to save
you a lot of time
in the long run and help you stay
consistent with your youtube content
even when life gets busy which brings us
to
checklist tip number 10 shoot photos for
social media
so these are a little bit different than
say thumbnails although you might use
those as well
thumbnails are really optimized to be
a youtube thumbnail whereas social media
you might think well
when i put my new video out what if i
had a cool photo
that i could use as a swipe up or a call
to action on my instagram stories
do i have a cool shot of maybe in our
case we do tech reviews
do i have a cool shot of this microphone
or this camera
that's kind of more in like a lifestyle
setting that i could use
on my instagram profile or on facebook
as a still image
do i have any social media content that
i want to create
to promote my youtube video later once
my youtube video comes out
have i got a few extra photos extra
video clips
anything that i might want to upload on
igtv or make an instagram reel
just a thought where again even if you
just pulled out your phone
and shot some content that is for that
video that's going to come out later
now when you edit that video post that
video optimize that video
now you've got content that is on your
phone where
you're just on the couch saturday
morning you haven't taken a shower that
day chilling with the fam
but you're like hey the new video is out
and i got a bunch of stuff on my phone
that i can use
now to promote that video i can upload a
cool photo on twitter
i can you know share on these different
social media platforms which can help
give you an edge
because if you want your post to stand
out on social media if you want your
content to stand out in a noisy world
you want it to be thoughtful content
creative content
and that can lead to more people
clicking through and watching your
youtube video more people discovering
you
more people subscribing more views and
never forget that your youtube channel
grows one view at a time
one subscriber at a time and so consider
taking
social media photos for so uh consider
shooting photos for social media as well
and so
quick recap here's your checklist and
let me know in
the comments especially if you're
watching this on youtube when is your
next
batch shoot day when are you blocking
time to edit the videos on your hard
drive
when are you going to do the thing you
need to do next
to stay consistent with one significant
post per week
on your youtube channel number one get
your video right your camera's right
your battery's right number two
get your audio right do you have your
mics charged up are they ready to go
number three how's your lighting
is your lighting set up number four how
can you make your set better is your set
good to go number five
get your shirts ironed it's time to get
that wardrobe dialed do you want to
schedule a haircut
before your next shoot whatever it is
number six
get your videos outlined ahead of time
we use google docs number seven
shoot the video show up powerfully and
you're gonna be
so much more confident because you're
that much more prepared when you get to
this stage number eight
shoot thumbnails after you've shot your
video and don't just shoot one
get six different poses like this seven
different poses like that and you'll be
able to pull from that cluster of photos
later
and you'll be thankful that you shot
extra options for your thumbnails number
nine
shoot extra b-roll if needed an extra
footage if needed
and number 10 shoot photos for social
media so you can promote your videos
later i hope that this checklist has
been helpful
apply the three strategies and the ten
checklist tips
and my friend you're gonna be able to
put out more content than ever before
and the content's gonna be better
well i hope you enjoyed that episode and
you wrote down
all 10 steps for creating your next
youtube video again these are the steps
that we still use here at think
for all of our youtube videos and these
are the steps that i'm using when i'm
solo creating content on my side channel
as well so
i can let you know that these steps if
you follow them one
by one by one will really help you when
you are creating content for
your youtube channel now if you have not
rated or reviewed
this podcast i want to encourage you to
go over to apple itunes
rate and review so that we can read your
review here on the podcast and today
we've got one from
spanomano he said finally i've been
making videos for a while now but
even with good reviews and positive
interaction i wasn't growing
now with the tips in these episodes i
have a path to take
i have a path to take to get where i
want to be thank you so much for leaving
that review
and letting us know that this content is
valuable for you
it means so much to us when you leave
comments on youtube or when you rate and
review the podcast
over on apple so after this episode
take a minute to go over and do that
step and
if you are ready to rock your youtube
channel and you want to grow
this year then you need to sign up for
our seven-day free
youtube influence challenge this is a
huge event
that we throw a few times a year here at
think where you can join us
for seven days for free where we walk
through our proprietary process
of how to get views and subscribers and
grow a highly
profitable and highly influential
youtube channel
so you want to make sure that you
register for that class at
tubeinfluence.com once you've registered
you're going to join
our free group where you'll get instant
access to the entire community
of people just like you ready to grow
their channel
we go live every single day for those
seven days
teaching you the exact process that we
teach inside of our signature academy
video ranking academy so make sure you
sign up at
tubeinfluence.com for our next
seven day free youtube influence
challenge
well i am excited if you are a reader
like me then you want to make sure that
you are here
next tuesday for our next episode we're
going to be sharing with you the
five books that every youtuber needs to
read
sean myself and the think team are a
group
of learners we love reading books and
we've distilled this down
to five books that you should be reading
this
year these books are going to help you
grow your channel going to help you with
your communication
and ultimately help you become a better
leader so
make sure you are here next tuesday when
the podcast goes live
to learn the five books that we
recommend that you read
this year thanks much for watching or
listening and we'll catch you in the
next episode
bye
you